vaping could be to blame for nearly a
hundred severe lung illnesses the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention just announced an
investigation into 94 cases where EES
cigarette users inhale the vapors only
on CBS this morning our consumer
investigative correspondent and her
warmer and a Warner her name has not
changed spoke to an 18 year old blames
vaping for his own lung injury and Anna
now we're hearing he wants others to
stop good morning to you good morning
Gail that's right it's important to
point out that what happened to this
young man from Florida is different from
the lung injuries suffered by teens that
the CDC and several states are now
investigating but chance Amerada says
the severity of his lung injury was a
wake-up call for him and he thinks the
consequences should make others think
too it felt like I was genuinely having
a heart attack
I like care having a heart like I was
having a heart attack that's how 18 year
old chance Amerada describes the feeling
when his medical emergency began about
three weeks ago I would say like my
chest felt like it was collapsing and
tightening up and I couldn't breathe
emergency room doctors told him his
right lung had a hole in it and had
collapsed I just freaked out and they
said your lung has collapsed
you have to go to surgery right now his
Instagram videos show the tube doctors
put in his chest
two days later a surgeon operated to
repair the hole in his lung the surgeon
told CBS News a Murata's lungs were
inflamed which could have come from
something he'd been inhaling but now
you've never been a smoker a traditional
sever yes what have you been using hi
jewel jewel Amerada says he started
using jewel a cigarette say year and a
half ago when he was 16 he now believes
joules caused his lung injury so we
started a social media campaign to get
others to get rid of their jewels
thousands of messages have poured in
over the past few weeks you inspired me
to stop as well as many other teenagers
I used to vape for about two years now
and I finally decided to stop I didn't
know I'd be able to reach people from
all around the world and it really just
touches my heart
doctors told CBS news it's possible al
mirada's vaping may have contributed to
a small pot
in his lung blowing out causing the lung
collapse Jewell declined to comment on
his case but around the country the CDC
and state health department's are now
investigating something else what the
CDC calls 94 possible cases of severe
lung illness associated with vaping in
14 states from June 28th to August 15th
of this year it's not clear which brand
or product the individuals used or what
substance they were inhaling you first
started hearing about these cases how
long ago oh all within the last month
just just a month yes the chief medical
officer of Children's Minnesota
hospitals dr. Emily Chapman says her
doctors have been treating four boys and
girls ages 16 through 18 with acute lung
injuries they don't fit anything else
that we have previously worked on
understood about lung disease that's
more typical in teens so essentially
you're seeing a pattern a pattern that's
different from what we've seen before
yes this is throughout the entire lung
so on the chest x-ray the whole thing
looks abnormal equally throughout the
entire lung for example take a look at a
normal lung on an x-ray and here in a
cross-section view now take a look at
that same cross-section view of a
patient in Hawaii whose doctor says he
has the same type of acute lung injury
associated with vaping Chapman says her
patients decline rapidly in just a week
you're basically saying that over a
week's time their lungs are failing they
go from healthy adolescents to really in
a life-threatening situation
Chancellor odda says his experience
frightened him but the response was
inspiring if I'm able to have such an
effect on the world I think I would go
through it again just so that I could
help as many people as possible now as
we said Jewell declined to comment on
chanson Murata's case but it said it is
monitoring the reports on those other
widespread lung injuries this is
dramatic stuff Anna what's the prognosis
for these teenagers you know
unfortunately some of them are still in
the hospital and doctors say they really
do not know whether their lungs will
return to no
or if they will sustain permanent damage
to their lungs they just can't tell
right now some teens in Wisconsin did
report in vaping THC which you know is
one of the active green ingredients in
marijuana and the American vaping
Association we contacted them they say
that they believe that that's more
likely what is causing the lung disease
here is THC or illegal drugs not
nicotine but again nobody actually knows
the answer to that right of mine is if
you're under the age of 21 or you're a
nonsmoker to stay away from this stuff
it's not worth it really glad chance of
sell is is sharing his story though I
think it helped a lot of people maybe
thinking about it or doing it thinking I
need to stop yeah he's trying to
influence other teens you don't make a
difference and I thank you